[Music]
what's happened unexpected episode of
wells that there's another episode of
that has around Hannibal Burres I'm Tony
true I sound like that man oh very
excited this morning me too good know
about so this one listen man we got a
we're gonna get through this
what happened folks is that we had a big
Mensa booked you know you're supposed to
start at 11:00 a.m. which is uh 5:00
a.m.
handsome Rambler time I think for the
podcast we don't start I think we
usually start work at 2:00 most times at
their earliest I think Coachella was an
earlier one maybe we started at 11 or
known there yeah
but yes so I I overslept and I'm not
even hung over any I ain't got a proper
amount of sleep it was just well didn't
you wake up and then decide to take
another nap I woke up and it was just
where I woke up at 9:00 and I responded
to your text about getting a camera crew
which is also why I feel kind of bad
because other people yeah all right and
I woke up at 9:00 and I was again nice
you got a camera crew and then yeah then
I was like let me get and it was one of
those with my body I only need about 20
minutes mo and it's gonna do that on his
own no alarm or anything silent silent
ringer silent Rangers ha ha yeah I mean
I was gonna call but I just figured it
would have both of you guys were on
rapper time it would have followed up on
death
years and also I live very close so even
if I gaiden up like right at 11 would
have been salvageable it's all good
life is life were [ __ ] has happened Liz
it like I missed one of our podcasts
yeah and we still doing a podcast that's
how well I was wondering and my phone
started blowing up and I'm like why are
people asking me all these crazy
questions oh yeah because you got the
notification his own yeah cuz it's
connected to my email and then yeah then
I ensure no I can't what I did a salvage
you know the podcast so we're gonna
answer some questions but you know what
else are some other stuff I use that app
Toro for the first time this week Airbnb
for cars Airbnb for cars Toro net a
podcast violence is just something I'm
using and have a good time with yeah so
uh Toro I read it a Tesla through Toro
that [ __ ] is buttery that's a nice car
Ritter that Tesla that [ __ ] is nasty so
you convinced you're gonna get one I
think I'm gonna get one and I was about
to buy one a few months back yeah you're
saying I was hyped up off of the Elon
Musk book I was reading a book and I
just got hyped off his vision in an out
win in order to Tesla the thing about
ordering a Tesla online that [ __ ] is
like I've had more trouble with seamless
orders meaning it's very it makes the
car buying process super fast you can be
from start to finish on each detail of
your car start to finish three minutes
if you fast buy the car and putting in
payment info putting in your down
payment putting in it it's fast what
color you want what you want the
interior to be what all that [ __ ] you
could do it that fast you know what I'm
I think that you should wait on the
Tesla because I've been hearing news
about how they're trying to make an
affordable version of it yeah
and so I've been
I can't remember exactly what the
wording was but basically Elon Musk is
saying that he's trying to make like a
consumer-level
Tesla I don't want the consumer that but
here's the thing once they do figure out
how to make it more affordable
the Iowa yeah I think the other the
other ones price is probably gonna go
down if not going down the look the
luxurious nosov it is probably gonna go
up
oh sorry if I were you I would wait
Celeste so here's what happened
yesterday what everyone I'm having the
one I have the battery was running low
electric car and so I go to the Tesla
place to get it charged it doesn't they
have the supercharger and a regular
charger the supercharger would fully
charge a car in about 20-30 minutes the
regular charger days 30 miles per hour
yeah and so I get that I didn't know
that and I say man I got a month and I
had to pick up my niece and nephews and
Southside so we can go downtown I mean
our families at all man okay well you
can leave your car here charge it and
we'll give you a loaner yeah and so they
gave me a different Tesla mm-hmm
to drive with though they gave me the
one with the goddamn oofy the crazy-ass
doors I hate that one the kids love it
DeLorean or the kids yeah exactly seems
like it's like back in the future my
niece and nephew they would like
[Applause]
they were so hyped I felt like because I
was you know I was unexpected I didn't
know I was gonna had a concert hour
before I got it and so what I knew I was
picking up my niece and nephew yeah
that's the perfect people to pick up if
you got doors that go up that's great
so uh the doors like automatically kind
of or do you have to man you know you
press the button which is oh you press
it on the screen
yeah this is a little weird cuz you look
and then it's I was you know I'm new to
it so when we parked somewhere I was
having trouble yeah closing it yeah so
it looked like I was just downtown with
the goddamn doors up trying to show off
we just got a stand about a car that is
a cool way to pull up on some young kids
just park the car and hit the button and
then the door comes up yeah like if
you're 15 you're like oh [ __ ] and
they're my age you're like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro folks out on Grand
Street downtown there were like oh [ __ ]
okay and the kids my nephew's 8 I think
my my niece is 11
yeah so they were hyped and she had a
great critique of the car while we were
driving she's like this is very fast
it's very quiet it's quiet in the car
and it's very futuristic its
environmentally friendly and then she
didn't even know it was electric I told
I told it was electric she was like wow
because she wants cars to be able to
teleport to cut down on fossil fuel
usage oh she's a she went past electric
she wants teleportation she wants
teleportation does she you got a very
ambitious uh yes we walk past that
big-ass Walgreens they says Chicago
theater they crazy
yeah it's like a mom it looks insane and
they got sushi and [ __ ] in there she was
like why is this Walgreens so nice they
need to stop invested in that and invest
in the schools I was like [ __ ] my niece
has a better person than me yeah you
stories about your nieces
yes she seems like a very local person
yes he's yes he's oh man yeah yeah she's
smart she's a smart girl so we took them
when my I said John Burroughs marker
Burroughs and my cousin Nikki mm-hmm
her boyfriend and his daughter we all
went to see spider-man homecoming yeah
yeah how was it it's really good
you don't dying in right I don't die in
and sorry for this boys I don't I don't
die in spider-man homecoming gift for
you
so that means sequel money sequel I'm
making a sequel who know but it's good
and as objectively I enjoyed it I'm only
initiative of Mike a minute or something
yeah I come in and get my get my quick
laughs yeah get out of it I saw some
tweet saying like yeah kill that [ __ ]
again I got a nice laugh on it you know
and what's funny is that how weirdly was
not now at the beginning of the movie
yeah like every movie that we go to it's
dark and I could sleep I could sleep
anyway movies are like heroin for you
you get I don't know what it is my
nephew stopped sleeping in the movie my
mom's are in this movie had my mom my
mom legit woke me up right when she saw
my first scene popped up she's like this
she'll seen in the night and they're not
straighten up breathing I was up to
rested where I think I was nodding in
and out that during the first 15 for
something but I kind of knew it I was
feeling a little sleepy going in ah yeah
this is gonna be a sleep but then it's I
don't know how you do it especially in a
movie that you're in I would just be
like sleep asleep man and you know what
it is I think here's what it is about
movies mentally for me is that I know
for them I know it's a movie so you can
go see that [ __ ] again you can go so you
can go plan again of course next time
we'll take some adderall mm-hmm and I'm
gonna see this movie with a fresh
Wakeman you know a movie I saw a door
and that [ __ ] was insane goddamn what
Jake Gyllenhaal when he that crazy ass
photographer do Donnie Darko what that's
just the first movie that popped in my
head that's crazy but I know what you're
talking about where he's a paparazzi guy
yeah huh
Nightcrawler Nightcrawler Nightcrawler I
saw that on adderall in New York and I
like this [ __ ] gonna get out
Oscar he's getting Oscar his performance
was very riveting yeah he was going in
he was a friendly yeah he was a
sociopath turn that [ __ ] yeah yeah man
it was uh it was a good one yeah I saw I
saw was looper in Vegas on Molly yeah I
couldn't I didn't I couldn't not talk
about looper for a year now looper Oh
Molly you seen looper yeah that's a
crazy movie to watch so Molly was just
[ __ ] a time traveling and
trying to kill himself
and all that [ __ ] it was I was I was
thinking this is one of the best movies
ever yeah she hear me in 30 years which
I stare into your eyes to strange
your face looks backwards do you know
what's gonna happen you done all this
already as me I don't want to talk about
time travel we both know how this has to
go down so why don't you do it old man
too
and died just take your little Conover
between your legs and do it boy looper
was so good as a movie I might put it on
my top 10 albums list oh you asked me
what's your favorite album Illmatic
[Music]
Stankonia looper like that's a movie
right rocky for spank onea whats cracka
with judo no I was up all night doing
the episode then I got out really early
set these guys up and it's pretty much
yeah that rambler life and then all of a
sudden my phone starts blowing up with
weird ask questions yeah and so let's
get to the questions we haven't done
this since episode we did this in the
early episodes so uh let's do a question
segue song you ready yeah okay here's
the first question actually the first
one that came in is a is a solid no it's
not the first one that came in but I
think it's one to have a good discussion
about this guy John John John says I've
got ten thousand dollars to invest where
should I invest it it's a good question
it's a solid question and I'm that I'm
not one to I wouldn't tell you where to
invest it but I think suggest if the
things that you want to invest in or
you're interested in
just research that said google alerts
for it if you tie if you like some
stocks said google alerts for certain
stocks or hot stocks or companies that
you're interested in follow them and or
if you're in some real estate start
learning more about real estate
this is podcast i love called the
BiggerPockets podcast mm-hmm and it's
helped me learn a lot about doing real
estate deals and things so so what I
would say is you know you use the ten
grand to first just learn about you know
different things that you want to do and
get and get a lot of information and
then make your choice from there but if
you want to I mean if you want to flip
that ten real quick that's a lot of
money for drugs yeah so you could take
that ten stacks buy [ __ ] ton of drugs
you could probably quadruple that money
by the end of the week the end of the
week you turn ten in the forty hey if
you got that kind of clientele man you
could flip yeah but then the risks those
risks but there's return its hurt so
depending on how high reward exactly
dependent on how adventurous you are how
ballsy you are or you could go the other
way and be born as I'll put it into some
retirement [ __ ] or whatever yeah I mean
there's lots of options out there you
get yeah so it depends on your
personality and what kind what are your
goals
how much do you want you want to be do
you want to just turn that into 40 or 50
do you want it to be a hundred thousand
or million it's a lot you could do
gamble that check do you you could
gamble it double it up if you see a good
bet double that's it up or even get more
money you know a lot you can uh try to
buy a baby with that [ __ ] by you could
buy a bait mm-hmm
depends on where you at but you you know
you know I think the I think the return
on the baby is more like tax breaks and
[ __ ] you get I think you just get the
baby for free and then they give you how
the tax breaks there's a lot you can do
you can just I don't know man
the the I won't say the world is your
oyster but a very small sliver of it is
yeah that's in with that 10k yeah you
can uh you could start a food truck no
not with thank you you need more than
that I've already looked into that
really yeah you can't do that with 10k
you just the truck alone just the truck
alone and then you're gonna have like
then you have issues with then you got
to get the equipment then you got to get
the licensing they make you get like
this GPS thing like there's a whole
bunch I looked and I said legit look Jim
looked into it be short on that I was
really enjoyable for me cuz the
conversation before was very kind of
whimsical and fun and then once we got
the food truck you like not tell you
something brother I was gonna make us a
me and one of my good friends back in
the days was gonna we were gonna do a
sandwich truck and uh yeah that got shot
down real fast so I think that was
mostly for like like licensing and
permit costs and all that [ __ ] like
there was a ton [ __ ] ton of fees so I
think that's where really came from and
you know sanitation I got a really good
one here yeah okay this one comes the
first name just the first day okay this
one is crystal alright so you got two
questions first question its dating I
have a rule that if a guy I'm seeing
randomly facetimes me without prior
notice I must abort mission immediately
I mean why would you do that
lo and behold a guy I really like
unexpectedly does the unthinkable
according to my rule I should block him
for disrespecting me what do you think I
think as a terrible rule it's a terrible
rule I go for the face time early me too
I go in for the face time right even if
I haven't met her I would her face time
first of all there's a lot of times just
so heard it I'm that catfishing
catfishing I was about to say not a
murderer but could also be a murderer
yeah I'm not or vice versa this is it's
not a murderer face unless you have it
tattooed as a but uh yeah face why is he
who she thinks
crystal what she trippin she trippin I
think this might be something I wonder
if this is somebody I've randomly
FaceTime and then she's she's throwing a
subliminal maybe yeah well here's the
second question on unless you wanna stay
on this oh yeah yeah alright alright cuz
why why does the might have to give her
notice to FaceTime I the way I look at
it is like this it's the FaceTime is the
future like you know video video people
already do a snapchat I mean what's the
difference is just live what the [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] is the problem what you
got you don't have your makeup on was
what's the problem what is the actual
root of the problem of unprecedented
FaceTime right I don't see it one time
uh Chelsea for ready FaceTime me out of
nowhere
yeah and it was like it was two years
ago yeah I think it was a Tuesday or
Wednesday was in LA while I was working
on why yeah and for some reason I was at
a party where my [ __ ] goes was like
juggling fire yeah bad guy yeah and I
wasn't expecting to face that so that I
answer the FaceTime and she looks she
say what the [ __ ] where are you just
burning man it was just somewhere mother
was juggling fire swallow fire unicycles
yeah I think you have the choice whether
to answer it or not no and then you say
that shouldn't be a reason for you to
not [ __ ] with a guy yeah and then you
say did you say that to the person you
said it I have a rule if a guy I'm
seeing facetimes me without prior notice
I must abort a mission abort mission
dick did you communicate that with them
or are you just going off of that as
you're silent
yes if you say to them don't cuz if you
already seen them what's wrong with
FaceTime says I don't know what the
problem yeah I think I think she might
just have some kind of a weird phobia
about getting caught off guard on on a
video also says you can just cover up
the camera yeah and then see what a a
yeah you could take the you could take
the power position which I do sometimes
even if I sometimes I face time people
and cover up my [ __ ] you know see what
you know that's a good that's a very
good that's very good advice actually if
you got a problem with FaceTime put your
thumb over to God naturally and you got
the upright you got the upper hand you
could talk that [ __ ] [ __ ] you doing
FaceTime with me I know that [ __ ]
there's your answer right there covering
for words
[Music]
excellent advice Hannibal excellent
excellent advice let's go to our set her
second question do you want to do the
second question always do second
question
oh go ahead so long ago my mom told me
not to cut my hair too short for fear of
looking too masculine or like a lesbian
her fears not mine
fast forward to 2017 I want to cut my
hair now and all and I also have to tell
her I'm a bisexual what should I do
first haircut I'll come out to my mother
I got another deal you get a haircut go
to a goddamn good as like black or
Latino Barbara yeah and have them cut
some dope graphics to say I'm a lesbian
in the back of your head FaceTime your
mom yeah and so you knew and say mom
look at my new haircut and then
bada-bing bada-boom
you did it you got your haircut you get
you get one of these so while your face
they say so you break the news like this
in those boys mom mom no all right all
right next question
this one's from Isaac hey Hannibal I'm
really sad that I haven't spoken to my
dad that I don't live with in about four
months because he has problems with my
mom and he thinks I'm some sort of
sidekick I miss him
what do I do you pull up pull up
wait but age has a lot to do with this
because what if he's like 14 goober up
lift up you can't you can't do it I
don't think you can do over lift unless
you're 18 yes you can't miss best that's
not the barrier here is all right spoken
yeah isn't that the right you saying all
right
he said spoken so he can just that means
he hasn't called them yeah he hasn't
called them yeah so it's weird to call
now so you got to pull up oh you say
just go yeah or just [ __ ] call the
guy and just be like hey look I'm
sticking with moms but I miss you I
don't want to say and I just want to say
what's up and there's everything good
and and the story I'm assuming this
person is how do you take this person I
say they need to pull up if you're old
enough pull up pull up to the career
yeah pull up pull up with some beers
mm-hmm pull up with some beers and some
tacos and have a drinking contest about
not a contest you don't want to get into
contest drinking with your parents I
don't think is this something you have a
drink with your parents I don't want to
play even on play beer pong if I did
play beer pong I wouldn't want to play
beer pong with our parents you get what
I'm saying
yeah oh I have a drink'll mom no way I
would love to play beer pong on my dad
really
yeah my dad's awesome like that drunkard
yeah he's a jolly drunk so he gets drunk
and we're playing games that's a great
night and you don't play games so it'd
be nice to play games that get you drunk
with my father but that's just me I
don't know all right this one's from
Jenelle so she got a text he said I
received the following yesterday want to
go to Jamaica Sunday and then she put
probably who's this and she said if she
got invited makes you said if I don't
know the person should I go and hope for
the best
if I know the person that don't like
them do I go and maintain a very very
heavy buzz regardless should ask to
switch destinations
valise wait who's asking her to go to
Germany just as she got a text from she
don't know she replied who's this maybe
oh you know what it might be somebody
she knows yeah don't go to Jamaica with
a stranger that's stupid find out who it
is
well you gotta go on a chemistry date
first but find out who it is you can't
just blindly go to another country with
somebody yeah you can't no I think
that's horrible advice I don't think
that's a horrible advice I'm saying you
can if you see so just do it take a trip
with a stranger or use the plane ticket
go to ditch the guy do what you gotta do
and come back if he's an [ __ ]
well that breeds resentment yeah
um now you should definitely not go
across into another country somebody you
don't know know find out who it is I
know it is but that's a strong move yeah
whoever made especially because his name
is not locked into her phone it's a
strong move I've done come to this city
move but it's another city and yeah in
the yeah when you're involving passports
the past four different games yeah but
you know women like islands duh
[Music]
this episode of the handsome Rambler is
brought to you by Bevo it's the first
and only shape system designed for
coarse curly hair and sensitive skin
step your game up man
step your shave game up we got deals for
you just get to get bevel dot-com slash
Hannibal and we got deals for you man
we're gonna make you look right we're
gonna get rid of your razor bumps and
we're gonna help you look smooth with
bevel I mean they got the whole full
stage system and the futuristic tremor
the trimmers nice take it from me I know
about staying trim so I know about
tremors and they got the full shave
system that's good so check them out at
get bevel calm slash Hannibal that's
getb e ve elle.com slash Hannibal and
live your best life stay smooth stay
trim get the ladies I'm not even looking
at the questions anymore
no no there's two well coming in still
when he still be ones yeah well not even
there's a stupid ones but there's a lot
of obvious ones it's funny when people
with that I'm married ask me I guess I
could give I give pretty solid advice I
live life in a way that needs advice
though but I think I provide perspective
perspective I provide a solid outlook
sometimes you need you just need to
shift the angles I tell people that all
the time like if you're moving Leonard
linearly and you're you got your eyes on
the prize and you're moving linearly and
you're not progressing it's because
you're looking at it too linearly yeah
and you got to move to the side a little
bit it's like it's like fighting take
the side step and they hand them with
the quarters
have you ever thought about fighting
competitively no no never
no no not even like some it's too
time-consuming some backyard not some
backyard [ __ ] but some independence
fight club [ __ ] not now it's too it's
too time-consuming if I if I was the
fight competitively I had up to train
hours every day like that's not
something that I'd rather work on music
the podcast DJ I wouldn't be able to
travel maybe you start or find a
fighting League where it's understood
with say hey y'all [ __ ] ain't
really training like that right you just
kind of are everybody cool right
everybody cool right you ain't out here
like wrong wait you ain't now who
running 10 miles a day
[ __ ] are you good
yes Reyes understand just how you know
we just going yes no ringers or anybody
that's on some real [ __ ]
another problem with that is that you
know I'm on a you know I'm on the stage
a lot with you particularly and we take
photos and stuff I don't want to have
missing teeth in swollen face and busted
nose exactly I don't want that I wanna I
want to look crispy so and it's gonna be
hard to travel with all that gear when
you have a broken toe injuries
yeah injuries is not worth it I had a
weird moment yesterday I was leaving
this bar and people were saying you
should come to the Continental come to
the Continental no no I'm not going to
the continent so I don't need to go so
for am bar wasn't I didn't need to do
that and then uh there's this guy he had
a cut on his face he was one of the
people oh you going to the Continental
and I just joking he said oh man I ain't
going to the concert
you already got into a fight there last
night just talking about the cut he was
like yeah isn't that from a fight I got
hit by a car and I was like ooh was that
the end of the conversation it wasn't
the end luckily I had an old friend
there cleared it kind of helped smooth
it out she was like but everything is
good now and you're not and if she
brought up somebody that was worse
injured or something
it's like she's really it was a if he
was just meat it could have been a it
was still an awkward moment but it was
is she helped it she smoothed it out oof
that was I'm still right I'm still
getting chills off how terrible I felt
in that moment I got one for you
yeah new questions all right here I like
the way this one starts out and it's
nice and short this one is from Jason he
says hi Anibal me and my girlfriend are
thinking about trying out swinging any
advice on how we should go about it how
do you feel about swinging in the first
place about swinging swing I don't I
haven't done that swapping swapping yeah
no I'd rather oh you know what I haven't
haven't when I've been in a relationship
I've been in some situations where we
realized that the other couple was
trying to do that yeah it was subtle but
I do remember and it was a situation
where the tray if we swap it wasn't it
wouldn't be as good for me
I think I know where you're getting that
with yeah well like man my my girl way
badder than you
yeah I mean I just the swap situate mean
it was I think I'm too much of uh you
know I'm a big basketball fan and so I
always look at trades like how does this
how does this work out for both sides
yeah
and would you like but would you do it
like they would have to be a private
situation right like you in that room
and I'm in that room and then we swap or
would you do it like orgy style like
side-by-side parallel yeah I don't wanna
I don't know about orgy style just cuz
my [ __ ] might try to high-five me or
something yeah that's I'm not in there
I'm not I'm not into having another guy
in the room it's not my thing it's a
turn-off for me so I I definitely
wouldn't do that but here's a okay this
guy wants to get into swinging just I
think you just look that [ __ ] up for
your area it's kind of that I think
there's some crap I go to reddit.com
slash slash are slash swinging yeah many
ways to find winger do whatever the [ __ ]
your yeah that [ __ ] you'll find I mean
the way I look at it is if you think
that that's gonna help your relationship
you should do it like if you think that
your relationship needs that kind of
excitement both parties are on board and
you guys are open-minded enough to let
it not affect your relationship or make
it healthier go for it yeah but if you
feel like there's a it's a risk and it
might get in the way of feelings and
[ __ ] like that if you got any kind of
notion of it going sour don't do it so
I'm trying to think if I'm making up
this stat or if it's something I heard
and I'm regurgitating but I hurt
maybe that swing cos couples have lower
divorce rates I hear well
you go but also my visas Meaghan I said
you know what because I just talk for a
living
look that [ __ ] off and if it's true take
that into consideration as well yeah
what does that but yeah just look that
[ __ ] up you know and get in I don't know
get into it everybody likes different
things I don't like raisins honey
well we we were outside got to DC we
stopped at some diner by the rental car
spot October cuz I remember the shows
that this was around so this is October
18th 2014 me you yachters papas that's
right at this diner yeah
while waiting for a rental car and you
ordered something you did like no
raisins right I ordered the yogurt you
said no raisins or no I specifically
said I asked her I said does this I was
like it's yogurt granola granola usually
has raisins that I'm like can you make
sure that there's no raisins and or yes
she went back and she yeah she went back
to the kitchen actually came back and
said yeah there's no raisins in it yeah
okay now you could go from there and
then there were raises and it there were
raisins in it
you spiraled a spiral for the listeners
out there I don't know if we ever got
into this but I know I have a legit
raisin phobia like it's a legit raisin
phobia
what's the fovea cuz it's not it's not
an allergy it's not an allergy so if you
eat raises you know about am I gonna die
doesn't that about the time read you
know how to do that [ __ ] I think they
they just they make me feel they just
the taste of them that everything about
raises just grossed me out it's just
like it's um even if there's like
raisins next to something that I'm
eating it to meet like you could compare
it to like having a piece of [ __ ]
next year steak they didn't touch but
there's still a piece of dog [ __ ] on
your plate that's how I feel about
raisins
that's a strange dream raised I can't
[Music]
oh that's buttery raisins Tony don't
like them reasons he doesn't like
raisins reasons he don't like that was
nice that that that setting on there is
pretty is pretty beautiful okay yeah
uh-huh this one young lady I'm gonna
keep her name secret she just messes hey
Hannibal there's one lady says hey
Hannah won't try to [ __ ] Eric Andre help
me out
snap [ __ ] snap shot him that [ __ ]
statue me tipless well FaceTime in that
[ __ ] if is code if they tell me their
[ __ ] this cool yeah that's it you
trying to [ __ ]
show him the parts that you want him to
[Music]
say that time on the Instagram on it
sweater on a snapshot what that plan is
oh that's the hook right there
[ __ ] on Pancham
[Music]
yo that was nice Pinterest you you
[ __ ] Pinterest no I absolutely do not
sometimes I come across like a Google
thing with Pinterest and there's cool
[ __ ] on there that I see but I don't
really get Pinterest what is Pinterest
about exactly I think it's just I can't
explain it we would have to have an
actual guest that's a Pinterest expert
okay I think you post stuff you could
sell stuff on there I think it couldn't
be well utilized and I want to try to
start moving stuff up there I have
somebody do that on my behalf
actually I had you know I saw some I I
was looking on Twitter and I saw this I
saw some interaction with somebody who
social media manager somebody that
worked for some other magazines and
different things and I said that could
be cool to have somebody really just
handled my social so I'm not doing the
posting all the time but just keep
everything wait this person is posting
but have stuff that's not goofy content
but it's in my voice and they're posting
a few times a day on Twitter Instagram
just to keep the flow going and all that
and so I set up a meeting with is this
woman mm-hmm
I meet up with her in Logan Square and
we talk about yeah I want to have you
know I tell her that exactly that like I
want to have some money you know run my
socials and just build it up and just I
don't think I'm using them as
effectively as I could be so it'd be
nice to just have you know a machine you
know you know social media a social
media expert kind of just do that [ __ ]
and Pinterest was part of like I think
there's a way to use Pinterest in an
effective way but I could tell I could
tell the I could tell when somebody
hires somebody to do it
yeah and I don't like it but anyways you
could be you could tell sometimes I
could tell a lot oh he didn't post that
I don't think yeah rick ross tweeted
this got the cat video or Facebook you I
can tell definitely what [ __ ]
have their Facebook yeah cuz they'll
have some she's like this is crazy
huh it is just be anything that's what
you're into baby from Cash Money he
poses some is but it's just but they
monetize it especially with Facebook
pages with millions of followers like
they get like a lot per post posting a
certain certain content I mean do it for
like you specific ones that you don't
[ __ ] wit but don't do it with your
Twitter because people [ __ ] what you on
Twitter hard cuz they legit know it's
you right
what does it mean you know I will still
post on my own I'm saying just other
specific promos abut the Twitter I can't
about Pinterest whatever this is a
better story but yeah I get what you're
saying and I wouldn't Donald Trump need
somebody like that Tom's from that
[ __ ] is a hole anyway yeah now
let's move on that type of person for
the president sweets
way more to me by about 10 foe that's
weird the President of the United States
tweets more than a comedian yeah that
what is it that's weird
watch he's gonna make it the reason that
presidents are not allowed to use
Twitter anymore
it's gonna go it's gonna go on the law
presidents aren't allowed to tweet so I
meet up with our in Logan and just tell
her the plan I want to do and just kind
of I want to grow our socials who's
socials
like in the visuals of it and how I want
to build stuff and and all it is and she
got her notebooks he's just writing
stuff down and yeah yeah yeah I applied
and writing everything sure uh-huh and
then we and then we in enemies she said
yeah I should get this is on a Wednesday
she said I should be able to get a plan
to you by Friday and then never heard
anything really yeah why were you social
aspirations too high
I don't know what it I haven't heard
anything never heard anything from her
since then and then our and I checked I
was like maybe she got sick I'll check
but I looked at her Twitter she was
tweeting about nonsense maybe she was
just a big fan and wanted to talk to you
oh but I thought that was just nothing I
mean people do weird I mean I don't know
if we've talked about this before but in
Australia there was a guy that pretended
like legit pretended like he was gay for
at least four or five hours just to hang
out in the crew cuz he was he was
hanging with that girl he was hanging
with a girl and she wanted to bring her
friend and she was like don't worry he's
gay so it won't be some random dude and
he's my best friend so he pretended like
he was gay but he was actually a big fan
was that her idea his idea I didn't get
that deep into that information but he
admitted it because I was smoking a
cigarette outside and then he admitted
it to me so hey by the way I'm not gay
I'm just a really big ham but birds fat
and I'm like but was he was he we're
doing gay mannerisms or was he old was
he playing it up no he wasn't playing it
up but I was legit having conversations
with him about it I'm like yeah you know
you're in the dudes you know what it is
you know what it's you know like it's
just I don't remember exactly the extent
of it you know what it is what but you
know he wasn't like hey guys like he
wasn't acting like that but he sure
was like making it like he you know he
played the role in his in his own way
now I think that's gay
yeah that's gay it's always that's what
I mean to act gay to be next to another
guy that's gay right so it's a lose-lose
for him I think but I don't think that's
comparable to me setting up a meeting a
business meeting with somebody that does
that job for a living and then them just
wanting to have a conversation with no I
don't think it was that I think I don't
think that's that's not analogous at all
I've said this person does that job and
then they wrote down the stuff and we
didn't really even talk about anything
yet we talked about work I don't think
and I don't think she was a huge fan
like that she wasn't yeah it wasn't
gassed or anything like we talked
business yeah I guess I just wanted to
slide that glass sorry boy Paul doesn't
have to say it I don't think those
equate okay but that dude was definitely
weird
[Music]
next question here's a question and it
says Tony trim help tune they said
what's up guys is it still is it weird
to still [ __ ] with WWE at age 20
whatever girl if someone finds out that
I still like wrestling it feels like I
get judged right after I love UFC two
and people are fine with that but as a
whole convo if it's fake wrestling [ __ ]
ain't fake they get [ __ ] up too hello
but seriously thoughts would help what
he's getting judged for watching
wrestling one who gives a [ __ ] just live
your life live your [ __ ] life I don't
watch wrestling like I used to but I
still respect it for entertainment I've
been to three live wrestling events over
the past couple years I went to wrestle
Kingdom in Tokyo yeah I went to WWE
payback at Rosemont Chicago
suburbs of Chicago and I went to
Wrestlemania it's great shows it's a
great live event and I don't know the
storylines and I don't know the you know
sort of emotional connects when I'm
rooting against somebody I'm just there
for the action and as a spectacle
wrestlers put on a great show and they
do get hurt and a muhfucka actually I
don't know if it's in Zola somebody
yeah just recently got like a heart
attack or something right either talking
about that one know if the event I was
at last year that one [ __ ] up for real
broke that broke his neck but [ __ ] his
[ __ ] up in a non fake wrestling way
where it was just just quiet in this
[ __ ] arena for a little bit and then
just swept them away
that's web to me it just took so they
got they have to bring the real EMTs I'm
sure in a yes I should as real memo
[ __ ] do crazy stunts into the into
the rope and it bounced off that mat and
again this is how we've got about in
again it this is a serious situation
that has developed at ringside you can
see the emergency medical personnel are
bringing his stretcher down here to uh
to work on Enzo amore and guys again
amore hit so hard I believe the second
rope and then into the into the bottom
rope again I was trying to get his head
underneath the rope and he hit that rope
and that rope it is just like a cable
it's as hard as it could be and hit his
head on the mat
knock himself completely out and so yeah
I mean if you enjoy enjoy rest enjoy
what you enjoy
[ __ ] [ __ ] whoever don't [ __ ] with I mean
I guess [ __ ] I'll tell you to choose
dollars I was in the room I was in the
right uh wrestling when I was like young
when I was on the borderline of not
knowing if it was real or fake when I
was like a child as soon as I figured
out that it wasn't real I didn't like it
I still don't it's not my thing right
but it's obviously a multi-million
dollar industry and it's under ten
million
you know one time I was in Milwaukee I
was at this place called the vanguard
and they have like a WWE night I think
were you there with me I don't know if
you're there not only are you weren't
there with me and I so we went we just
went there to get some sausages and
drinks and the place was packed and
[ __ ] were like cheering
standing up yelling screaming and I'm
like damn like this is there's a lot of
entertainment value it's like it's a
soap opera it's a show you like your
show it's a good show some I watched
some [ __ ] shows and if someone's
gonna judge you for liking a [ __ ]
show and go tell them to [ __ ] themselves
and I enjoy when somebody is funny and
entertaining on the mic that was the
main the wrestler was cool with some of
the special moves with great Shawn
Michaels kicking people in the face yes
Larry is hilarious
[Applause]
the razor's edge
[Applause]
Razor Ramon his move some of this [ __ ]
look cool their entrance how am i
interest says interest is with the music
that's really where it's at right Coco
good interest yeah ho Koga ninja
undertake them yeah whole kögel with the
Voodoo Chow now as far as Hogan goes
[Applause]
yeah I'll talk about that in my jump
well that's how I found out about voodoo
ciao yeah Jimi Hendrix was a whole call
can walk him out to that [ __ ]
DX had to ill as entrances
[Applause]
[Applause]
drop this man
the rock or rock on the mic Lou oh dear
God you see my name's Billy and I just
won King of the Ring but there's one
problem everybody still thinks that I
absolutely suck and then at that point
Billy your house started to shake the
heavens opened up and God Himself spoke
to you and said this Bob but my name's
Billy it doesn't matter what your name
is in rock also was known for selling
people's moves really well there's a
thing in wrestling where sometimes
people don't sell well like if they have
somebody do a move on them they don't
they don't act like it hurt them or they
oversell or they under order that's part
of it that's part of being a good rest
look but you sell it you know if there's
a champion or that somebody has a big
wrestler you sell their move to look
good so there's a compilation of the
rock selling the Stone Cold Stunner and
so the rock when he would get some stone
cold son it's videos of him where he
just flops crazy around the ring and
makes it just look like it's just
incredible you know move and so that's
there's a lot of different elements to
it that I think people would appreciate
what do you think is like the age limit
for a man to stop being so into fake
wrestling I don't think if you like that
[ __ ] you like that [ __ ] I saw people of
all ages that yeah
WrestleMania so you have no qualms about
like a 65 year old guy solo at the spot
being like really into it have so little
time to be worried about
somebody like wrestling or not not
worried about it but I'm just saying
like a grown-ass man what are you doing
time I [ __ ] live his [ __ ] as long as
it ain't long was he on the way to the
wrestling [ __ ] I ain't in such a rush
that he just hit me with his car or
something just don't affect my life
don't did you smash into my car while
you're on the way to watch wrestling
just drive cool if you even if you
running late that's your fault yeah
that's it that's it for me okay if you
want to just watch that [ __ ] and enjoy
it what you gonna do it if somebody
challenges you watch some wrestling then
ask them about see that they enjoy I'm
pretty sure that's some [ __ ] in
there and then you can't make fun of the
[ __ ] they like and then say it anyway
like why you being so me anyway you were
just what you just did to me so let me
just watch when you wanna watch yeah
[Music]
we'll be at a FYF fest July
25 got your face first your face first
what now what is that why I'm some char
killer [ __ ] right there yeah look your
first four so yeah man yeah f y FS f YF
s noise in Lauren Hill tour in September
and October I'm on select dates get them
on my website Hannibal Burres calm get
merchandise Hannibal Burres calm I don't
have any merchandise but I just want to
fill out the sets and sound for fish we
need to get some merch alright thanks
for listening you guys an advice episode
this was fun we hadn't done that in a
minute you know [ __ ] flow it's good yeah
right you want to end with a song
[Music]
I don't even really give a [ __ ] oh
[Music]
that's nothing Silas song I got it I
ain't got it the song gay pirate my
father stop it while we pop like it
twelve bottle rockets put them in a
light socket put swell bottle rockets in
the light so I can drop it throw it out
the window falls into the back of a
pickup truck
and pulls up your mamma's Nintendo what
all right let's stop so was it perfect
perfect thank you
[Music]